today we're giving you the latest
updates involving activision blizzard
talking about how the modding community
is trying to improve the gta trilogy and
more my name is devonte and you're
watching gamespot news
the biggest news of the day involves a
bombshell report from the wall street
journal it levels numerous allegations
at activision blizzard ceo bobby kotick
including that he had knowledge of
numerous sexual assault and harassment
claims at the company's various studios
he reportedly withheld information from
the board of directors on one
particularly serious claim and is said
to have threatened to kill a former
assistant in a voicemail in 2006 though
this is said to have merely been a
hyperbolic statement he regrets in the
wake of this kotek released an internal
video message to staff but a group of
employees are now staging a walkout you
can head over to gamespot.com for more
details on the allegations and the
latest on what's happening
now let's switch gears to gta modders
across the internet are taking it upon
themselves to fix the myriad of issues
plaguing grand theft auto the trilogy
the definitive edition
since the collection of games launched
players have pointed out that there are
a number of things wrong that leave all
the included entries far from definitive
the trilogy which includes grand theft
auto 3 san andreas and vice city has
issues that range from typos to cj's
fingers growing to horrifically long
lengths or visibility ruining rain
thankfully modders have been stepping up
to fix some of these issues on nexus
mods users can find better rain by
insanity 666 which lives up to its name
by turning the torrential storms in each
game into a much more pleasant rain
shower
but alright it's been a big week for far
cry 6 as the game's new vos insanity dlc
has launched alongside new breaking bad
inspired cosmetics the game has also
received an update that fixes bugs the
vast insanity dlc lets you play as the
villain from far cry 3 portrayed by
better call saul's michael mando who
came back to record a new performance
for the far cry 6 dlc and what's super
surprising to me is that this dlc is
inspired by roguelites
the expansion is not available to
purchase by itself so you'll need to
pick up the 40 season pass to get access
two further expansions are coming
focused on villains from other past
games including joseph seed from far cry
5 and pagan min from far cry 4. also
available in far cry 6 are new cosmetics
inspired by breaking bad which makes
sense giving the breaking bad stars
giancarlo esposito plays the game's main
villain and mando appears in the prequel
spin-off better call saul the content
includes a heisenberg theme outfit and
weapons while the fried chicken
restaurant los poyos hermanos is also
now in the game alongside special
outfits themed around the restaurant
they also fixed some bugs which means i
can finally play the game again because
my weapon wheel will work again
thank you
thank you so much
so did halo's multiplayer completely
consume you yesterday be honest let me
know in the comments and i'll see you
tomorrow
[Music]
you